Nous avons parcouru des milliers de kilomètres
en quête d'une arme
plus puissante que tout ce que nous connaissons
"Pourquoi êtes-vous ici ?"
"Pour faire du commerce."
"Mensonge..."
"...Vous êtes des voleurs"
"Qu'est-ce que c'était?"
"Il y a beaucoup de choses que vous n'avez pas encore vues"
"La Grande Muraille...
...est le seul rempart
qui protège le monde"
"Sainte-mère de Dieu...
que veulent-ils ?"
"Se nourrir !"
Ils se sont entraînés toute leur vie pour cette guerre
"Je veux combattre à vos cotés"
"Tu te condamnes à mort"
"Je te souhaite bonne chance"
"Ray, c'était pas toi"
"Tu penses qu'ils te considèrent comme un héros
"J'ai pris les armes par cupidité, et pour des Dieux."
"Cette guerre est la première..."
... qui vaut la peine d'être menée"
"Je suis né sur le champ de bataille
"J'ai combattu pour l'argent et les Dieux"
"Cette guerre est la première qui vaut la peine d'être menée"